على كل حال سالنا الناس ما الذي يجعل
الشخصيه الايجابيه شخصيه سامه نتابع
الاجابات
[موسيقى]
تتحول الحاله عنده فورا ظروف الاقتصاديه
عندنا الوضع الاقتصادي الامور يعني ممكن
شخص مثلا ممكن يزعجك يعني انت نازله مبسوط
امورك تمام نشوف شخص يعني تتحول الى امورك
امورك سلبيه فيها اصحاب طاقه ايجابيه وما
يحاول الموضوع دائما الى طاقه سلبيه وطاقه
ساميه عن طريق الانتقالات السلبي كل شيء
عندهم سلبي البيت يطلع الصبح سلبي حتى
تصحى من النوم في ناس بيصحى من النوم لا
اله الا الله محمد رسول الله يا ام ياسر
يا كريم يا فتاح يا كريم بيروح باتجاه
الانتقال يتعرض انتهاء حقوق لظلم لعدم عدل
الى عدم مسواء مثلا انا شخصيه ايجابيه
مثلا متفائل اطال الله
شخصيه سلبيه وسام بنفس الوقت
[موسيقى]
المحيط اللي حواليك البيئه اللي انت فيها
شوف البيئه اللي انت فيها سلبيه لو مهما
كان عندك طاقه ايجابيه لو مهما روحك
ايجابيرك تحول لبني ادم سلبي
الناس اللي حوالي الاحباط الظروف الاقدار
وبالمقابل اي شيء بالحياه بده شحن
والانسان اهم مكون
التربيه يعني بتكون من الاساس غير الواحد
مش متعود على صدمات او احيانا صدمه في
الحياه
وهذه احد الاسباب الكبيره
لانها صدمه بناس بكونوا ثقه فيهم او
احيانا في الدراسه احيانا في العمل فهي من
الاسباب الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]